foreign
[Music]
Spirit more than spending time with
family or in northwest's case pranking
her little bro you just gotta roll with
it and she's clearly in a pranking mood
for the festive season the nine-year-old
is having some fun at the expense of her
brother's song
in the latest video posted on the joint
Tick Tock account she shares with Mom
Kim Kardashian Dorothy has Dean Martin's
let it snow let it snow let it snow
playing while she holds up a kkw beauty
eyeliner she then proceeds to draw on
psalm's face while he's sound asleep
[Music]
all the weather outside is frightful but
the fire is so delightful after her
hijinks nor pans a camera out to show an
Elf on the Shelf sitting next to Psalm
seemingly planning to blame the Antics
on the elf with her caption having kids
is just there's no way to describe it
but it's a lot if you're sleeping around
North you might want to keep one eye
open why not her latest move on Psalm
comes after she pranked Kim last week
wow you guessed it she was sleeping
um
yeah wake up yeah I'm awake
so
North this is not funny I'm really
freaking out aside from North's
Shenanigans she's also been getting in
the holiday Mood by baking goodies with
her mom but the fire is so delightful
and since we've no place to go
let it snow let it snow let it snow man
it doesn't show signs of stopping and
I've brought me some corn for Papa
the lights are turned the way down low
let it snow let it
North also indulged in a special spa day
with her baby sis Chicago getting in
some r r
[Applause]
[Music]
are
[Music]
yeah she really isn't to Beauty she
loves
she loves hair looks that's her thing
and she loves a little bit of makeup and
clearly she loves a good prank too
and since we've no place to go
let it snow let it snow let it snow